what up space fam wilson here from anime
outpouring i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest and craziest updates
in the one piece story today we got some
epic but also heartbreaking moments so
make sure to stay tuned for that if you
do enjoy
seeing one piece reviews on this channel
and want to keep them coming
then the best thing you can do is smash
that like button and share this video
with your nakama if you haven't be sure
to subscribe and this is crucial
ring that notification bell and select
all or you will miss future one piece
videos
make this the day you subscribe if you
haven't already and while you wait for
the next chapter to drop feel free to
check out my growing one piece playlist
where i got videos about the supernova
the warlords the yonko and much much
more
link in the description i also spent a
long time on my most recent one piece
video
and longest video in the channel's
history where i looked at every yonko's
backstory and i'm really happy with the
way that turned out
so if that does sound like something
you'd be interested in definitely check
that link in the description for that
now without further ado let's jump into
it spoilers and
all the chapters called the kunoichi's
oath so as usual keep it in mind because
the title always hits harder when the
chapter puts it into context
but clearly the ladies of one piece will
get to shine in this chapter the cover
art this time
is pretty funny i don't usually mention
the cover art but i like the text
underneath that reads
luffy tries to study but he quickly gets
bored and we see luffy just laughing so
hard he's got tears coming out of his
eyes it hits close to home for me
because i tend to care way too much
about my grades in high school and
university so i can't help but
appreciate luffy's carefree attitude
here
and yeah although it's something small
it helps remind us that school doesn't
have to be
that important or everyone's path for
luffy who wants to be a pirate king he
doesn't need school
and it's the same for eichiro oda who
decided to become a mangaka and i'm
definitely not saying forget about
school but it is nice to have reminders
that it doesn't have to be
that big of a deal because it usually
does seem like the biggest deal when
you're in it
but that appreciated cover story aside
we begin this chapter with something
pretty crazy right away we get a clash
between marco the phoenix and big mom
talk about starting strong and props to
marco for having the guts to initiate a
confrontation with iyanko
even knowing as he says even more about
how dangerous big mom can be
than the rest of them do prometheus
doesn't match up well with marco the son
homie gets hurt
by marco's usually healing flames
surprisingly and marco comments that his
phoenix flames are quite unique
imply that there's still more to learn
about his fascinating powers
so it appears like as far as commanders
go marco is a great matchup for big mom
however just as there might be the
slimmest chance of hope big mom flexes
srianco's strength
and grabs marco pretty easily by the
neck telling pero sparrow to finish him
off he prepares a candy bow and arrow
which is pretty sick not gonna lie
i don't know why but i loved seeing
archery being brought into it and even
though moments ago these two seem to
have an alliance now it seems that
perispero will execute him as an
enemy and really you can't even be
surprised by that there are pirates with
more honor no doubt
but in general you can expect pirates or
people in general for that matter to act
like this
someone as strong as marco seems
completely powerless
sweating and being unable to move pero
sparrow comments that he's wanted to
kill marco on different occasions in the
past
how ironic and in a sense this might be
ironic because the one time he didn't
want to kill him but team up with him he
actually gets the perfect opportunity to
assassinate him
of course he's interrupted by sulong
carrot and wanda
who give perospero a good slash right in
the face
wanting revenge for pedro thus still
leaving some hope for a future marco and
pero sparrow alliance that i'd like to
see
not gonna lie even big mom is shocked to
see the soolongs and you gotta admit
kerechon be looking good i do like
perospero's perspective here because
pedro blew himself up and perospero had
to deal with the consequences and now
people want revenge
because this dude blew himself up and
heard pero sparrow you can see from
perez pero's perspective why he's
annoyed at this even if our loyalties
lie elsewhere i do like big mom's
response to all this she comments on how
she hates being on the sidelines of the
battlefield and just leaves perro's
barrel there
saying they can all do what they want as
she books it to the main battle big mom
says that marco can try to kill her
another time
but she doesn't have any souls to use
against him right now
in my mind if marco wanted to prioritize
pero sparrow's defeat right now he'd
help the sioux long girl since pero
sparrow ain't no joke
but the sulang ladies tell him he can go
on ahead
and that they'll take peril sparrow out
and at least there's two of them now
because when it was just carrot chun i
couldn't see her having a fighting
chance but this does help their odds
without us actually seeing what road
marco decides to take
stay or leave he does notice people
screaming about becoming demons and he
can't help but wonder
wtf is going on then we jump into
another interesting matchup zorro and
drake versus scratchman appoo
and i don't like apoo i just want to say
that right now but to his credit this
dude holds his own pretty well
as he mentioned he has the antidote and
as a result
there is murderous intent everywhere he
looks but he can't give it to anyone
because he'll get killed if that happens
scratchmen survives zoro's attacks and
seemingly hits his own allies with his
fighting music this is a bad move
strategically for queen to make i feel
like dividing conquer is a strategy
that's often used for beating your
enemies in war
but here queen is willingly doing it to
his own side turning them against each
other and appu
again to his credit goes on to block not
only zorro
not only drake but both of them at the
same time
he admits that two on one is a bit too
much but the fact remains he's doing
better than i thought he would do
against the combined forces of these two
supernova and i do love the back and
forth hate
between drake and apoo which is
definitely suggesting that drake and
appoo
might end up settling matters by
themselves while zoro pisses out to join
kinemon and the others and queen again
comments about drake switching sides
when he was found out but again i'm
thinking queen should try to finish him
off himself
rather than giving him a chance to take
out another valuable member of their
team but whatever
queen clearly has his own style and even
if it's not the most
effective and doesn't follow the art of
war he is entertaining nonetheless and
knows how to make chapters hella
interesting and intense
i do like it when he mentions the
strategy of crushing luffy's second
and third fighters early on because that
is strategic we all know that if zoro
and sanji were taken out people would be
shook af
including luffy himself to be clear i'm
obviously not saying i want this to
happen we need
zorro to cut kaido but i just like that
queen
is being smart about this and that makes
for an interesting antagonist
notably he does seem surprised that
vinsmoke judge's son is on the crew so i
look forward to learning more about the
significance of this
and queen's possible past with judge
then we jump to chopper and brooke
and this is where things start getting
bad for our guys
at first there's some light-heartedness
with brooke realizing he didn't catch
the virus
because he doesn't have skin blood
vessels or body heat
since he's already the same as a dead
body he's not affected by it and then my
skeleton boy brook says and i quote
i'm a little offended by that fact but
regardless i'm invincible
end quote absolutely love that bipolar
statement and reminds me how much
i love brooke definitely one of my
favorite straw hats and just when it
seems that chopper is figuring out
something important about the virus
robin points out that chopper's arm is
freezing
and he didn't even notice and brook
again chimes in with a scream and says
and i quote chopper's done for end quote
this is a serious threat and it makes
the urgency of getting an
antidote all the more important but i
still couldn't help but laugh at
brooke's response
but yeah as if chopper getting the fast
spreading virus wasn't bad enough we
jumped to the fight against page one and
ulti
versus nami and usop and as we'd expect
our two straw hats are outmatched but
nonetheless
their spirits aren't broken they won't
give in to fear
usable captures ulti with an instant
kill
green star devil attack and page 1 frees
her
but implies that she probably didn't
really need his help to escape from that
attack
then usopp summons bamboo spikes from
the ground but this technique just gets
called borin which is bs because
it is a very cool technique but the fact
remains that our two flying six members
are unimpressed and ulti continues to
charge
the now crying usopp and man when usopp
cries
that gets to me because i know how hard
usopp is trying to be brave
and useful and it hurts seeing him come
short of his ideal
like in this case ulti headbutts him
with a skull cannon
completely shattering usop's skull
leaving him seemingly unfit for battle
and i do want to say
because it must be said that usop's goal
is to become
a brave warrior of the sea and he
succeeded in being brave in this
instance he knew he was outclassed but
he stepped up nonetheless
yeah he wishes he was more useful but he
still gets top grades in my books
for being a brave warrior to the end he
can totally be pessimistic and hard on
himself but man do i respect how far
usopp has come
but after chopper has the virus and usop
gets his skull cracked we're still not
done
my girl nami is badly hurt she's been
beaten to a pulp
and although i like boa hancock a lot
nami is right up there with her as a top
tier one piece waifu
and seeing her like this it breaks my
heart she is completely
powerless here and we want to protect
her through the page
but we can't we gotta just watch she's
admitting it's over that ulti won
she cries and begs for mercy she knows
that if she gets head-butted again
by her she'll die nami says many things
like that luffy is an idiot and that
she's sorry
and that they'll leave the island you
know usual nami willing to be
tricky to get out of a tough situation
but then ulti wants nami to say that
luffy will never become the pirate
king and nami is crying she's at death's
door
and seems to begin saying it usop
understands he wants nami to say it
he wants her to be tactful to save her
life she doesn't have to mean what she
says
however in one of my favorite moments in
one piece to date
she decides to say that luffy will
become the pirate king
definitely and man if you're not watery
eyed
right along with her right now then i
don't get you
this is nami the girl who originally
tricked and used luffy to serve her own
goal
the girl who outwardly acted like a
selfish person she is one of the coward
trio and the only girl in the coward
trio making us even more protective over
her
we know her she's good at heart but
she'll be strategic and say what the
enemy wants to hear
if it means getting the job done but
here she refuses to compromise
no matter how scared she is she will not
say that luffy won't become the pirate
king
even if it means her life and man that
is so sad
and beautiful at the same time as i said
one of the best
most touching moments of one piece and i
know that saying a lot but it's true for
me
this is characterization at its best
ulti is shocked and says if that's how
it is
then die usop tells nami that she's an
idiot and to run
and right when it seems like it's all
over tama comes in with her lion dog
komachio bites down on ulti freeing nami
and if we recall tama's animal taming
devil fruit powers worked on the smile
user speed
so she could actually turn out to be
very very useful here
and maybe even make some higher level
smile users
switch sides but i'm getting ahead of
myself the point is
and eight-year-old tama comes in wanting
to be a kunoichi
and completely saves the day nami cries
out to her and it's just such a
beautiful moment
obviously nami's been sort of a kunoichi
in wano and she just made an oath that
luffy will become the pirate king so the
title has significance for that epic
moment as well but the point is the
girls
shined so hard in this chapter from
carrot and wanda to nami and tama
it was amazing and as i mentioned tama
could be a real game changer
if we take into account her devil fruit
powers but wow what
a chapter a big mom versus marco clash a
supernova clash
chopper getting the virus usab getting
his skull cracked
and nami and thomas absolutely brilliant
moment
we didn't see luffy and i didn't even
mind because this chapter was so
so good there's a reason this is the
best-selling manga
of all time and it's because beyond the
fighting it has moments like this
which shake us to our very core anyways
let me know
your thoughts on this chapter and what
you expect to see happening next
if you did enjoy this review and want to
keep the one piece reviews coming the
best thing you could do is smash that
like button and share this video with
your nakama
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit the notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future one piece videos
if you haven't make this the day you
subscribe
and while you wait for the next chapter
to drop feel free to check out my
growing one piece playlist where i got
videos about supernova
warlords the yonko and much much more
link in the description and specifically
check out my longest video
ever on every yonko's backstory if you
haven't
since as you'd expect the way these
yonko got to where they are
is fascinating af and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you